on the gou night a celebrity couple yes
who is it we wanted to
make it Sparks FLW backstage it's
incredible and was John and Emily not
just a coup are married and are you like
brangelina or you know benfer or we no
our our uh name is uh crunt we've
decided I see how you got there I'm not
sure why there wasinski just
seemed you know long and long long
winded so crunt felt efficient and sort
of do you use crunt a lot every
restaurant is that table on the back
available for crunt yeah we sometimes
send out Christmas cards like Christmas
with the crunch come have
a you do the traditional uh pouring the
pint of Guinness well we were shooting
at this uh Pub and and they asked me to
pour a pint of Guinness and I thought
this is going to be amazing and I'm
going to crush it didn't at all so there
was a crowd of people who were actually
in the pub I think our movie was very
tiny so there was no sort of locking
down of sets we were just there you know
people were there fre freefor all and so
there's a crowd of people watching me
pul the P who were very uproar at first
they were just like cheering and then as
the Pint just turned into a pint of foam
it just turn it just kind of dwindled to
nothing I think we' got a picture of the
Pint yeah
foam that that is sacr and also there's
a great I I'm going to Big up there's an
Instagram account called London
gimness I don't know some some Legend I
think he's some cork or something and I
basically people put sand him in these
awful P notoriously terrible Guinness
here in London and um you know it's like
no head at all loads of head like
sometimes a Guinness uh P of Guinness in
a like a heekin glass like sa dread sa
but that would be straight on there
yeah celebrity special I wasn't the herd
to oversee that that's terrible it was
really bad even Christopher Walkin was
like that's
bad but how do you get that so wrong I I
thought I was doing all right and it I
think it's the angle I think it's the
angle maybe too much gas in the pipe too
much gas in the pipe just like Jamie
[Laughter]
Doran
ni good it worked right it funny funny
yeah was funny that was funny is it true
that Emily Blunt did break your
spirit
it was a particularly hard day I will
say it was a very hard day it was we
were the drop ship no she didn't break
by Spirit but there was that moment you
you basically we're in this drop ship
set I don't know if you guys if you've
seen the trailer we're being dropped out
of this ship in our EXO suits and it was
a tiny set they' made the set really
small it was kind of like as big as a
sardine can and we're all in there it's
so hot in there there's no air in there
camera crew are like bumping into us and
we're hanging in the EXO suits and
harnesses so like the entire weight of
you and your suit is like on your ground
grin and like people are miserable
people are just like hanging like this
just waiting for them to sh action and
and Tom um that insatiable positivity I
can just see it just starting to unravel
you he was pouring with sweat I remember
looking at him and he was like guys
please please roll please roll and I
just looked at him and I just went oh
this sucks like that and he looked at me
and he
goes it's a
[Laughter]
challenge so I because you know what if
I start complaining it's on if I start
going down it's on yeah and I went Tom
it
sucks okay obviously lovely that Emily
wants to be in the film absolutely but
as a director is it then weird giving
your life partner notes it it was weird
because I was very nervous about it to
be honest I think we both were before
before we started shooting she said are
you nervous and I said I'm terrified and
she said oh good me too um I think it's
one of those things where people think
because we're both in the same business
we have the same experiences but I've
actually never been on set with her seen
how she worked I'd heard she was a diva
and I
just can't get Emily out of her trailer
stuff like that it's like and um no but
I think what it was is and it sounds
really sappy but it's true I think it's
the greatest collaboration I've ever had
in my career I I've never seen her work
and when you are actually in the room
and she does what she does it honestly
it changes the air in the room everyone
is just completely and totally stunned
by what she does oh
I this is what I have to say this is
what this is what I had to learn early
on in our oh that's relationship was
that British people are notoriously
terrible at taking compliments would you
agree just
like stop talk oh that's that's actually
what she did first I was like look I
just want to get out of the way I'm a
huge fan of yours
and I don't know if you found this but
I'm amazed when you're told that the set
is going to be a closed set yes you know
which means that only limited amount of
people necessary for the shot are going
to be on set it's it's amazing how many
necessary people are having a look I had
to do a scene in that film where I stood
by a window completely naked and then I
look down and all the crew were
like I was
like oh de and of course now I suppose
there'll be a whole new generation of of
kids who fall in love with this uh Mary
Poppins and so Emily your kids how are
they with it well I think um I mean my
youngest my two-year-old has a sort of
attention span of a fly so she watches
the trailer but um hazel who's almost
five has seen it and just absolutely
loved it and sort of wants to talk about
it all the time now and yeah it's it's
just really weird
your mother's marry po no but I don't
think she see I think she just thinks
it's normal she's like well that's what
this is what Sunny's Mommy does and this
is what my mommy does you know it's just
sort of like quite conversational for
her is it going to help or hinder
discipline at home oh hinder really yeah
I think so because she know she already
knows I can't fly she's like well she's
bake but but she did ask me to do the
voice the other day just out of nowhere
because she was quite sort of impassive
watching the film just sort of didn't
just sort of didn't reveal much of what
she felt and then the other day she goes
do your she's American of course sounds
American but um she go she go she goes
do you marry pin's voice and I goes spit
spot and off we go and she
goes oh and it was just so sweet and
they they quite like impersonated me in
the bathtub where where where I say to
the to the dolphin no no not yet and and
now the two of them go no not yet
like cool at all there was none of that
actually uh I don't know your work you
are a proper fan of I was full stalker
status yeah I was just like hey you want
to go on a date with
me no tell people how many is this true
how many times have you seen devil
whereare Prada I mean not 75 give her
take
72 no I it's one of those things that
back in the day us elderly people used
to channel Surf and um no one does that
anymore but ex like I
said no it's just one of those movies
that whatever whenever you're going
through the channels you just stop and
you I mean look has anyone seen the film
here
probably there people there's a sort of
Montage sequence where Annie Hathway's
got numerous fabulous outfits that they
go through and John one day I came home
and he was watching it and and he was
watching the Montage bit and he goes and
that's my favorite
outfit with the beanie well I couldn't
get Annie and so
God you're fluent in the French as well
aren't you absolutely not Oh I thought
you were fluent not FL I mean I did it
at school I did a level French but I'd
since gone out the window but I I get
really nervous speaking French and I
actually used to have a a stutter when I
was a kid and it's still the way that
that I still stutter when I have to
speak French it comes out when it comes
out when I TR French yeah Weir yeah all
right well let's not
I've seen the King
speech very authentic portrayal that was
me I was Colin F but but in French but
in French yeah we went to Paris for New
Year once and and you know my now
husband and our two friends were like go
on to find us a taxi because we need to
get to this place I said oh God please
don't make me please don't make me and I
hadn't had the guts to tell them
actually I do still stutter they were
like go on please and so I went to the
guy at the front desk I was like um I
could say everything apart from the word
taxi apparently so I went
um and you went taxi and I went yes and
he went taxi he s in English s in
French joh also I I did encourage him
that he would be welcomed more if he
stopped wearing a baseball cap because I
just said you look so American nobody
wears baseball cap oh that makes it
better you are so American take off the
basball I just wanted you to blend in a
that's just called prejudice is
what but he went out and bought himself
a Tweed flat cap no he looked awesome
was that good no he looked like
something out of a guy Richie film you
look great and he walked down the street
and it was like the sun came out cuz
suddenly a guy turned him and he went
all right
what what does that say about your
country that it's like well if you lose
the baseball hat get a just wear tweed
that's what it says you need it's that
simple then and was it nice cuz presly
having your children spending time here
with f dice because are they American
children you said it kind of snaring me
like this is get
weirder put your cap on you'll be fine
yeah exactly you like dry heed you like
are they
American have you given
[Music]
[Applause]
birth
godb it's worse than the film and then
an American came out of
her I mean they are semi American
they did become um quite uh well my
oldest daughter became quite British
sounding over the course of the year
that I was here from Mary Poppins and
she was sort of saying things like bath
and water and now she's back to
water you the little human and little
human popped out we've got a picture of
Hazel that as a mother that must be so
nice have 600 people
go it is very nice yeah because I do
that but yeah she's beautiful she's
amazing she so cute was it the nurse
that was very complimentary when she was
funny we were in the recovery room
afterwards and we had this amazing nurse
who came in and she looked at Hazel and
she goes damn your baby is so
cute and I went I went oh really she
went she is gorgeous and I went Mabel I
think you say that to all the mothers
and she went no I
don't she said she said when I know a
baby ugly I say you had a baby
that's
[Applause]
[Music]
it